welcome to this meeting of Baba District
Council cabinet I'm councelor John Ward
leader of Baba District Council and I'll
be chairing the meeting May first of all
remind you of some domestic arrangements
please ensure that microphones are
turned off we're not in use that you do
not interrupt other speakers that if you
are attending the meeting to speak and
persistently interrupt the meeting you
you may be asked to leave please ensure
your mobile phones are on silent or
Switched Off and additionally we will be
using e voting for this meeting on the
modern. goov app i' would like to remind
everyone present that this meeting will
be broadcast live to the internet and
will be capable of repeated viewing the
whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential or
exempt items if you make a
representation to the meeting you'll be
deemed by this Council to have consented
to being filmed by entering this meeting
as a speaker you're also consenting to
being recorded by the council and to the
possible use of those images and sound
recordings for webcasting and or
training purposes the council members of
the public and the Press May record film
photograph or broadcast this meeting
when the public and the Press are not
lawfully excluded I'll now move to the
agenda item one apologies for
absence thank you chair we have received
apologies from councelor Jesse Carter
councelor Daniel poter councel David
Busby and councel Derek Davis thank you
item two to receive Declarations of
pecuniary other registerable or non-reg
interests by members are there any to
declare nope item
three paper BCA 2326 to confirm the
minutes of the meeting held on the 7th
of November
2023 so starting at page five on your
agenda
pack
six P
seven page
eight page nine so Council Davis um on
page um seven paragraph
49.1 it keeps saying tables and I think
it's meant to be tablets just as a
matter of otherwise it reads rather
strangely
yes yes
tablets we'll get that corrected thank
you thank
you right so page
eight page
nine page
page
11 and finally page
12 so may I have a proposal for the
minutes please counc mcra and a second
celor Sally
Davis and right we'll now conduct the
vote thank you chair the vote is now in
progress
for
thank you members that is five votes for
that's unanimous chair thank you the
minutes of the meeting on the 7th of
November have now been confirmed item
five to receive notification of
petitions in accordance with the
council's petition scheme none received
thank you item five so that was item
four item five questions by counselors
nonone received chair and item six
matters referred by the over reviewing
scrutiny or joint order and standards
committees uh there are no matters
referred chair thank
you item seven forthcoming decisions
list cabinet members do any of you have
any comments on the fourth coming
decisions
list
no okay thank you moving on then item
eight is paper PCA 2327 Financial
monitoring quarter 1 for 22 uh 3 to 24
I'll now introduce this report as a
Cabinet member for finance assets and
investment I'm pleased to introduce
report BCA 23 um a to Cabinet the
quarter 2 Financial monitoring for this
year covering the revenue and Capital
financial performance for the period
April to September 2023 for both the
general fund and HRA starting on page 13
of the agenda
pack
it highlights the major year end
projected variances that are expected
compared with the budget if current
trends are maintained the actual outturn
at the end of the year will be higher or
lower than the amounts currently
predicted depending on performance over
the rest of the year so for the general
fund appendix a contains the quarter 2
Financial monitoring page 18 contains
the background which briefly summarizes
the challenges and pressures we continue
to face these do remain a problem but
there is hopefully light at the end of
the tunnel with CPI inflation now down
to
4.6% in the forecast position you'll see
that the headline for quarter 2 is that
we are forecasting a yearend deficit of
900,000 which is $922,000 worse than the
budget surplus of £22,000 that was
predicted and also further deterioration
on the position group reported at
quarter 1
the national pay award and the results
of the pay and review pay and rewards
review have added pressure to the
Staffing costs quarter two overall
salary costs are projected to be 2% over
budget after use of the contingency the
Su costs in public realm being
reallocated to Baba following a review
of staff and asset
utilization the recently announced
increases to planning fees will take
effect in year reducing the deficit to
an extent and we will see the effects of
this in quarter
three as usual page 19 summarizes the
variances for the service costs income
and funding and Pages 20 and 21 show the
detail of variances for each
service the largest single variance is
on planning income as it was last time
but this has reduced by uh for and the
planning income has reduced by £420,000
and that is a slight Improvement however
on quarter 1 this is still being offset
by vacancy savings so that there is an
overall adverse variance of £375,000 for
the development management Serv
service other significant changes from
qu to one that have contributed to the
worsening position are an increased
adverse variance for corporate resources
smaller unders spends in customer
operations strategic policy performance
and improvements and Housing Solutions
an increased costs in governance and
civil Civic office and public realm
overspends and these are for the reasons
stated in the
report the reserve movements are shown
on page
22 the capital program is shown on page
ages 23 to 26 we are now expecting a
variance of 9.4 million due to slippage
of the a1071 roadside commercial
workspace development and also the
courtz lane
regeneration the earmark Strategic
investment fund will be carried over to
next year as will bvw regeneration fund
although the cafe project is now
progressing
quickly as the report states with
complex Capital schemes it is difficult
to accurately assess the level of
payments that will be made during the
financial year we should FOC focus on
whether overall outcomes are being
achieved from the capital investment
rather than variances against the plan
for a particular year however we must be
aware that any Capital spend will incur
interest in mp costs and so delays to
Capital programs at the moment do help
our immediate budget
pressures appendix B contains the court
of due financial monitoring for the
HRA on page 30 you'll see a summary and
some background information the headline
is that there is a deficit of 1.54 five
million which is $944,000 worse than the
budget budgeted deficit of
62,000 as always the financial position
of the H should be viewed in the context
of the updated 30-year business plan and
we are now in the fourth year of five
years when we can increase rents by CPI
plus 1% at the moment however we are
under pressure due to inflation which
peaked at
11.1% only falling below the 7.7 7 7%
rent increase cap in July
page 31 summarizes the income and
expenditure variances and the
explanations for those variances there
is further deterioration in the
overspend for Building Services and
repairs and maintenance for the reasons
stated in the report these are partly
offset by the underspend in housing
management the capital program which
you'll see on page 32 is showing an
underspend of 1.77 five
million Reserve movements are shown on
page 33 and include the release of the
extra $943,000
that was approved by cabinet last month
to cover the forecast deficit for the
year the council's presedential
indicators are attached as appendix C on
page 35 we've not breached any of the
limits in the presedential indicators in
Quarter Two Karen Watling our corporate
manager for finance commissioning and
procurement is available online to
answer any of your
questions before opening up for
questions and debate I'd first like to
remove the recommendations in section
three of the report that the general
fund projected over spend of $922,000
the HRA projected over spend of $944,000
and compliance with the presential
indicators be noted may I have a second
for this
please counil of CW thank
you right okay so
now over to questions any questions from
cabinet
members
no
questions councilor
mcra so pres the information chair that
you're presenting might seem on the
surface to be extremely worrying but I
took note of the fact that it actually
falls within guideline limits that the
council has previously set and I think
it's fair for people to ask if there's
any reason for concern from what you've
said it doesn't and from reading the
report doesn't appear that way but could
you comment on what concerns may exist
in the longer
term obviously the um the current year
uh position for both general fund and H
uh is is challenging um but the
important thing is that um we we need
to look at those Trends and what it's
telling us and and the impact for next
year's budget setting um which is going
to be the most difficult that we have
had yet we will be meeting the uh the
shortfall in the current year from
reserves but we can't do that
indefinitely we will have to make as
very difficult decisions to ensure that
not just next year's budget but the
medium-term position is secure for the
council uh there are no more questions
from cabinet members um other members
present Council McLaren do you have any
questions no thank you
chair Council Parker no right then we'll
move into debate members of the
cabinet are there any further comments
you wish to make about the
budget
no council mcro doesn't seem a great
deal of point in um arguing these are
realities and our job is to deal with
those so I propose we just vote upon
this is it for
noting it is yeah yes thank you that's
fake of the point we're not actually
voting on anything substantive we are
noting the facts we we are noting the
facts councelor yes um and the facts are
that the pressures this year from
inflation interest rates um and
everything else uh has been a perfect
storm and also we're reaping the rewards
I use that word advisedly of the uh
continuing reductions in our support
grants um which have affected all
councils up and down the country over
well ever since I've been a counselor
and before it's a very difficult
position for all local authorities at
the
moment um but we'll get there we have
to
right I think um we'll move to the vote
thank you chair that vote is now in
progress thank you members uh that is
five votes for that's unanimous thank
you moving on to item nine paper BCA
2328 which is an update on the regulator
social housing referral and our current
compliance position unfortunately the
cabinet member for housing is not unable
to be with us today so I will be
introducing this report on her
behalf I'm pleased to introduce paper
BCA 2328 which provides an update on the
regulator of social housing referral and
our current compliance position as you
are aware a referral was made to the
regulator for social housing in November
last year regarding concerns about
compliance and that this resulted in a
regulatory
judgment the CEO Deputy CEO and direct
of housing meet monthly with the
regulator significant progress continues
to be made in many areas as listed in
section 4.3 of the report the regulator
is pleased with our progress and
continuing plans to deliver full
compliance
these meetings will continue until the
regulator is confident of our return to
compliance our compliance will be
reviewed by an external auditor to give
us and the regulator
Assurance members should be aware that
the table in section 16 of the report
shows the updated compliance position as
of the 10th of November due to the
timings of our earlier cabinet briefings
and we were hoping to have updated
figures today however our system is
currently down and the fix is expected
to be placed by the end of the week the
updated figures will also include the
position and compliance certificates
which are pending being loaded in our
system this will give members a better
understanding of our position the
director for housing is available online
to answer any of your questions so I'd
like to propose the recommendation in
section three that cabinet note this
report and I'd like to ask for a second
please councilor Sally Davis thank
you so members of the
cabinet any questions
counc mcro I think it'd be helpful if we
could just get a broad um summary of the
areas um in which improvements have been
made since this was last reported to
both cabinet and Council which areas
have seen Improvement and which areas
still cause reasons for concern I look
at the colors um but just the the the
the basic areas gas checks electrical
checks uh and the rest any can we get
any broad Direction uh just I think for
the general public to be have confidence
in this right as I said the the latest
figures are not available yet but I
don't know if um de de's online whether
she can give us
some uh indication as as to that that
broad direction that Council mcro has
asked
for uh yes good good afternoon members
uh so the broad direction is
positive sorry good afternoon members so
the broad direction is positive however
um it would be more helpful as members
have alluded to for you to have um some
figures um as was mentioned um by um
Council award the our system is down at
the moment and um we are waiting for the
fix to be um
applied however we are very confident
that that will be in place by the end of
the week so I propose that when we send
our weekly kpr our sorry two weekly kpi
document out that we send that to uh
cabinet um as well as the leaders and
portfolio holders um for Assurance and
what I also propose is that we put the
updated compliance table in the
minutes thank you Deborah thank thank
you Council m cette i mean the only
reason I ask is I still see some red
areas but predominantly I'm seeing green
and less red and less yellow and more
green so I just thought that was worth
pointing out okay thank
you okay councelor
Davis um I'm just looking at um Point
6.3 about the increase in damp and mold
i' I'd quite like a bit more detail on
that if possible is that because we're
discovering more because we're going
into more houses or is is and is this an
increasing problem for
us Deborah are you able to pick up on
that thank you yes so so we're carrying
out quarterly surveys now and um we've
got an external organization doing that
for us and and one of the this is for
the tenant satisfaction measures which
we have to report on for the regulator
but what this also allows is is to ask
some additional questions and one of
those additional questions is around
damp and mold so these predominantly
will be people that haven't reported um
to us before so that's why we are seeing
an increase um we've increased our um
contractor uh resource to uh meet this
need and we've also just engaged with
modisoft who are providing um uh some
software for us which has got uh which
is using AI so we can identify Trends so
although we are seeing an increase this
for us we're seeing as a positive um uh
pos positive direction because it means
we're picking up more of those cases
where people are not reporting to us and
were're able to become more
proactive thank you
Deborah any other
questions other counselors present any
any questions Council McLaren thank you
chair um in relation to 7.1 which is
about the contractor update um obviously
the previous contractor had a whole
house contract but I was wondering how
many contractors we now have in place to
replace that uh one service that we had
previously thank you thank you Council M
Deborah are you able to pick up on I am
thank yes we have two two contractors um
and um so so they've got the interim
contract and then we are currently out
tender for a a permanent contract and it
may be worth noting at this point that
we don't have facility to automatically
upload certificates with our current
contractors which means that there is
often a delay in US understanding um our
exact figures however this will be um
part of our new tender document going
forward so we'll have hopefully have a
new contractor in place from April or
contractors should I
say thank you thank you
thanks if there are no further
questions oh coun Parker you got a
question well thank you chair since
you're offering I'll I would ask but um
just because I'm a little bit Rusty on
this how how often are we receiving
these updates chair is this this is a
monthly thing quarterly thing how often
are we we receiving uh the regulator
updates there at least monthly
AR yes they are they are monthly and
they go to um the leaders and um the
portfolio holders every two
weeks Council
Davis yeah I know I noticed there's an
increase in water hygiene risk
Assessments in in November is is that a
result of the floods would that be water
hygiene
um no it isn't that that's it's because
they're on a cyclical process so as they
become due um you know that they'll show
on the dashboard and what we've had to
do with water safy is get a new
contractor and that new contractor is
just being mobilized at the
moment any Cabinet member wish to make
any comment through the through the
debate
no okay
we'll move on then to the
vote thank you chair that vote is now in
progress
thank you members uh that's five votes
for that's unanimous chair thank
you next item 10 paper bch 2329 the
quarter 2 performance report I'll now
invite the cabinet member for customers
digital transformation and Improvement
to introduce the report councilor
mcro thank you chair um I'm pleased to
introduce report BCA 2329 the quarter 2
performance report that is to say
covering the uh period from July to
September of
2023 the report is organized in three
main sections Part One deals with the 21
out comes from our current outcome
framework and that each is split to
various portfolios it covers our
achievements if you like um the
Performance Management is been become a
new crucial part uh using data to inform
and that leads us to part two which
indicates the direction of travel from
that data if you like the key
performance indicators we do like our
acronyms and then part three will inform
us on the plans for quarter 3 again for
each of the portfolios directorates I'd
point out that these quarters uh don't
life doesn't work in three Monon chunks
um stuff merges from one period to
another and uh that should be born in
mind we're going to present the report
um in the order it's for each
directorate uh portfolio um as it is in
the report and that would mean starting
with customers which conveniently enough
is
myself um I don't proposed to go through
every detail in the various sections but
I will note um for a couple of things uh
we are working on digital skills
sessions but um the outcome on that has
been people are um accessing them but
it's not a huge number more
interestingly live chat has seen 341
chats online since the launch in early
August and our callback service is being
rolled out steadily and 206 customers
have utilized that in the last two
months um we have carried out a resident
survey recently um and uh also tenants
annual report and that's reflected
within because got come to regards that
we want people to be able to engage with
us and Empower them to do so
71% of our 554 customers were either
satisfied or highly Satisfied by the
telephone service and 74% of the tenants
measure satisfaction service attendance
measures were satisfied with again with
the online
services uh practical matters we've
tried to reduce the length of time on
the telephone options 20 seconds cut off
the uh message you always get you know
press option one press option two 20
seconds is actually 20 seconds of
people's lives given back um our tenant
satisfaction measure survey is mixed I
think it's fair to say at 51%
satisfaction there's obviously room for
improvement there now moving to section
two and I'm afraid this means cycling
through some pages and I do apologize
for that direction of travel and the one
question that's always asked is uh how
many um how long is the average weight
time in seconds it's stabilizing at a
level I'd say is higher than we would
like and it's certainly higher than our
targets to about 150 seconds for a call
to be answered um it also should be said
we're getting slightly fewer calls per
day I noticed website visits are down as
his social media uh reach um which I
find interesting I think there's
actually a move away in some senses from
social media finally if I go to future
plans which is um after the direction of
travel the websites have been launched
they appear to have been highly
successful and I've yet to hear any
serious criticism of them and I find
them myself a great deal easier to use
um we'll be carrying out a tenant
satisfaction measure survey for quarter
3 on 150 tenants in each district and
we'll report that in the next
performance report uh there are quite a
number of
other items we've put into future plans
but those can be read in the report
itself um I'd I'll hand back to the
chair so that we can go through the
different portfolios in their respective
order which would be I think well-being
environment economy communities housing
and the health of the organization and
then I'll close off with the performance
Journey about how we'll present these
reports in quarters three and quarters 4
thank you chair thank you Council I'm
happy to take any questions obviously on
the
portfolio thank you Council mcro so uh
as Council mcro has has stated we we'll
go through this in in a sequence
starting with
well-being so who's picking up that's
councelor
saw problem yes uh thank you councilor
Ward
um we have had some very successful
events with orchestras live in sub
Hadley and tattingstone uh the sub event
was held with the Bridge Project
students and residents from Care Homes
and the Bridge Project is working to
extend its relationship with orchestras
live um the team has uh a focus on
helping people live independently in
their own homes uh working in
partnership with the NHS and social
providers um the strength and balance
program where the objective is to reduce
the number of Falls and time in hospital
um I'm glad to say that there are rising
numbers uh of people participating in
these uh workshops
um we've uh launched a youth prescribing
project uh with a youth worker embedded
at the Holbrook
Academy um to help students uh with
their um mental health issues um a great
deal of Officer time uh was dedicated to
planning for the healthy behaviors
program of fiood suffk with its focus on
weight management smoking sensation and
physical activ AC ity uh the launch date
for this is uh and was the 1st of
October um residents can refer
themselves uh or be referred by GPS or
social Prov uh prescribers um it's
interesting to see that the um most um
prevalent issue is um weight
management um one benefit of all this
work is a more effective relationship uh
with regional and uh local Health
Partners thank you
chair thank you Council saw next we've
got environment and uh councelor Sally
Davis will be picking that up on behalf
of councelor
Potter thank you yes um the environment
team hosted local climate action Road
shows in October there were three in
Hadley Sudbury and Holbrook um they were
also involved in one that was in
bramford which I went to and that was
well attended and provided a wealth of
useful
information um I think one of the most
important things is that Baba District
Council has put out a call for land to
plant trees um basically we need land
owners to come forward with land so that
we can increase our tree canopy in Baba
currently trees only cover 10% of the
land in baba um and the council aims to
increase this to at least
15% to help nature recover and increased
biodiversity and of course also it has
an effect when it comes to flooding we
need more trees so the team here is
working with suffk Wildlife trust and
the Woodland trust and land owners are
invited to take part and that includes
Community organizations individuals
businesses and
Farmers um and finally Community
consultation is underway for a cycle
route from kle to cop do um this project
has secured fun funds for design and
feasibility work so we're in the
consultation phase
now thank you Council Davis next economy
and Council mcro will be covering this
on behalf of councelor Derek
Davis thank you chair now I have to say
I was only made aware shortly before
this meeting start that I'd be covering
economy and the thing that I take most
from the extensive amount of information
is just how broad ranging the economy
portfol folio is um our aims are to
support um businesses to be green
resilient Innovative um to encourage
Innovation Enterprise creativity and um
there's so much going on there but of
course a lot of this is working with
other people uh those are primarily uh
the businesses and other organizations
who have also got an interest in these
areas um to pick out one would be very
difficult difficult uh there simply is
such a vast range of them I mean it's
four slides just in section one but it's
looking for redevelopment of key
employment sites and I obviously have an
interest in the bransom Regeneration
area being in my ward but there's so
many others vanas Deli worsted and
spron uh work continues in a whole
variety of areas with um uh universities
and educational facilities there's um
Town Center regeneration being supported
but as I say there's a great deal when I
look forward or rather to the um
performance measures and the direction
of travel
kpis um economy and I come 10 does show
a rise in uh vacancy rates in the town
centers of Hadley and Sudbury but that
is something that we have been aware of
for a great deal of time
um it doesn't mean nothing's being done
finally plans for the future and again
I'm just sliding through a single
slide uh we're delivering or looking to
deliver uh ongoing suffk wide business
support schemes via the UK shared
Prosperity fund these are for startups
Net Zero but but Net Zero being a
feature and producing some form of
economic growth we're looking after all
for better paid jobs in our district um
it was interesting to note the
incredible moving Cinema in Sudbury
which took place recently I just love
the idea of putting a cinema in a vast
big van and having people sit and watch
films where they couldn't previously I
think that's a nice Innovative approach
um again I'm happy to take questions on
this or rather ask the officers to do it
for me since they know more about it
than I
do thank you Castle mcro
moving on next is communities councilor
sa thank you councilor Ward um work
continues on the development of the
people and place plans uh also known as
the like touch neighborhood plans where
Baba is one of five pilot areas in
England and Wales um there is interest
in this from Parish councils who want to
use the process to develop a future
vision for their communities um but as a
council we do need to know uh what role
this initiative is going to play in
planning in National planning policy or
it won't get off the ground um there are
a parish councils who wish to proceed
but have asked us well what is the
objective for this and uh we uh will be
asking for clarity from the Department
of leveling up on this it's a good
initiative um but it is uh uh somewhat
um half finished at the moment um we've
spent a lot of uh time on focus on Savor
communities uh with anti- social
behavior week in activity activity in
Hadley and subury so the public
understands how the protection system
works and also uh to raise awareness of
victim's rights um f on for that uh
multi- agency meeting about how to count
counter uh antisocial Behavior due to
the influx of uh visitors uh to dead and
veil was held over the summer um we have
made a bid under round five of the home
office safer streets fund uh to deal
with neighborhood PL uh crime violence
against women and girls and antisocial
behavior um every police force across
England Wales has been offered up to1
million to deliver a range of
interventions um we look forward to
hearing uh about this um obviously
looking forward um we agreed as a
council of safeguarding policy um there
was a uh very successful town and Parish
liaison meeting um held on the 30th of
October feedback um that uh councilors
received about this has been very
positive and um uh parish councils and
town councils um were very forthcoming
with their um with their
ideas thank you
chair thank you next is housing and
councelor Saul will be covering this on
behalf of council
Carter yes I'm multitasking uh today
um vulnerable and homeless residents
um have secure and safe places to live
um obviously our policy in this is to
prevent homelessness and I'm glad to
report there was a 42% increase on
quarter 1 as regards successful
preventions um 18 Empty houses have been
brought back into use uh 21 grants have
been given to adapt houses to the
changing
circumstances of tenants as regards um
uh stair lifts and Le level showers um
obviously um one of uh our big uh
indicators is the tenant satisfaction
survey in
Q2 um the question about providing a
safe and secure home 76% uh were
satisfied a well-maintained home
64% and overall satisfaction levels
66% as regards the direct ction of
travel
um one of uh our FOC our renewed focus
on our tenants is engaging with tenants
who are dissatisfied with the way their
complaints are handled and coming to a
resolution um our officers have held a
housing Improvement day um to to focus
on increasing tenant
satisfaction and we've increased tenant
board membership with five new tenants
um coming onto the board and held three
board meetings thank you
chair thank you and lastly I'll cover
off the health of the organization in
terms of achievements these are measured
against two outcomes the first one
develop and Implement a comprehensive
people strategy the key achievements in
in chair there was a a section I thought
we might discuss uh s community
infrastructure Levy under one of the
previous items because though it falls
in one portfolio it's actually dealt
with through the planning and I wondered
if councelor Davis had some information
on some sill projects that have been
carried out I apologize for
interrupting okay that's okay no problem
Council Davis are you able to provide an
update uh no you go ahead I'll I'll I'll
I'll do mind later
yeah yeah um Community infrastructure uh
Levy um plays a very important role and
eight um projects were awarded um money
from the district council Community
infrastructure Levy in September
2023 um these are funds paid to the
district council by property developers
building in the district so a total of £
25,800 was awarded to a range of
projects in including footpath
resurfacing improvements to community
buildings um a contribution towards
facilities for the disabled and play
equipment and these projects uh were in
the parishes of Acton flatford and East
berol um Lavenham Boxford cockfield
stanstead and
Sudbury um another project was awarded
to over £3,000 which was um another form
of uh funding from developers section
106 funding and that was the
refurbishment of Boxford Pavilion and
then there are locality Awards which are
administered through individual district
councilors and over £4,300
were was distributed from this which
included the refurbishment of squash
courts at orist Academy in Sudbury and
the installation of a defibrillator in
Holbrook thank you right back to the
health of the organization that's
okay there wasn't a SE separate section
for Sil it was embedded in within
communities and the problem is the
portfolios do not necessarily align with
the sections of this report and there
was some embedded within economy as well
exactly so it's it's just a matter of
organization
okay right yes so uh in terms of the
health of the organization achievements
um there are two outcomes that the uh
achievements are measured against
firstly develop and Implement a
comprehensive people strategy and uh
recently the KY achievement here is that
there's further work being done on the
equality diversion and incl inclusion
that's progressing well and we've also
Rec recruited menopause Champions across
the
organization and in the summer we had
another successful intern
program the other outcome outcome
provide effective management of the
council's finances um the the key
achievements recently here are we've
completed the system testing use
acceptance testing and training on the
new Finance
system I will ALS also make a mention
although it doesn't directly relate to
either of those outcomes um one of the
biggest achievements obviously in in the
past few months has been the adoption of
the joint local
plan direction of travel for the health
of the organization uh you you'll see
from the the indicators on page 70 that
mostly everything is is going quite well
um I will point out though that sickness
has increased a bit but it was very low
in quarter 1 um planning applications
are being determined on time majors are
um actually being determined within 100
uh 100% of Majors have been determined
within time um but miners have dropped
from the high 90s to the low 90s per
although still well above the 70% Target
and all other indicators are above
targets which is
good looking at plans going forward the
the main uh item that we're focusing on
now of course and I mentioned it earlier
this afternoon and that's the 2024 25
budget the pay and reward review is uh
anticipated to be completed in quarter
three and also we're be rolling out the
leadership and management development
programs and that's all I wish to say on
on that so now um I'll ask any members
of the cabinet do you have any questions
on what's been heard and what's been
said so
far C Davis is Dea still with us on deah
is debah still with us
um is she deorah yeah I think she is yes
right okay I've got a question about
page 69 where it talks about the
affordable homes built or acquired um
for babber and and we go from 2022 to9
um I'm interested in how we've gone
about that and how we've done it a bit
more detail about where they were built
and where the two came from in the last
quarter right okay thank you uh Deborah
can you pick up on that I think most of
them are section one or six Acquisitions
aren't
they oh Emily yes oh Emily or Holly
might be up yes that's probably a better
option than Deborah isn't it Holly are
you able
to sorry H yes John's right they were U
mainly section6 Acquisitions where the
council purchased the units from a
developer that they're bound to to
provide under the 106 agreement by
planning um so we have had I'm just
looking at the spreadsheet now and they
were in uh nedging nedging with Norton
at ju Meadow and those units and they
were both
Bungalows thanks hly any other
questions other councilors present you
oh councilor saw um I'm interested in um
uh I see that the number of um
antisocial Behavior cases received
um
is
increasing this year
um now I know that we've been doing a
lot more training on on this issue and
and as I said in my uh report um
increasing awareness of how antisocial
behavior um should be uh reported but I
was just interested
in where that where what these cases
were um are there any particular Trends
um that we should be aware of and that
we should be um focusing our efforts on
preventing thank you is anyone able to
answer that it's um it's an interesting
question um or is that something we
should take away and and get back to you
on I think that's um Council mcro you
don't have any further Insight I just
noticed that the final stat in outcome
15 is that no triggers have been called
for the last six quarters that is a
trigger where an ASB case might have
achieved critical level and there have
been none for 18 months which seems to
me um I have to say I have in my own
patch certain number of incidents of air
be incidents involving I'm afraid to say
introduction of security cameras which I
really never wanted to see but um it's a
fact of life but the fact that none of
these have gone to to trigger more
serious action I think is at least a
little bit
reassuring well thanks for that but um
we will get some further information and
report back to Cabinet Council s thank
you any questions from many other
members councilor
McLaren uh thank you chair I wanted just
to refer to page 70 which is about the
numbers of days sickness which the
figures quoted are per full-time
equivalent I'm not sure that gives us
the picture of sickness absence in the
organization and I wondered if it was
possible to see
um a sort of print out of numbers of
days taken at one time so is it a lot of
people taking the day off or is there a
lot of long-term sickness and I wondered
if that information was available thank
you thank you council mro do you have
that information or I don't think so I
think it could be could be broken down
into absolute numbers the full-time
equivalent measure is used universally
simply because it gives you a broad
measure if you start to break things
down into individual people there's a
difference between somebody working
part-time and full-time um and you could
end up with skewed data um a breakdown
of of fact details I'm sure is available
from officers and we can ask those if
they can supply it I think that's
perfectly reasonable
yeah we yeah okay thank you councilor
Parker yeah thank you chair um I'm
interested um councilor saw you talked
about the light touch neighborhood plan
um I can't immediately see it in the
report here for give me if I've if I've
missed it in in the report but I'm
interested to know um anyway how long
that pilot is is running for and have we
got any dater on how many I think you
might have mentioned it forgive me if I
if I missed it but um how many parishes
and or or towns might have expressed an
interest in it at
all yes I I can um because
um the uh director of planning gave us a
presentation on this at the Joint
cabinet
briefing um and I am
quickly um looking at this uh light
touch 20 oh thank
you c m do you have I might be able to
help a little bit it's a floated idea
from yes central government uh act
actively working on one or in dialogue
about creating one
1 two three four five six seven8 9 10 11
um about um 12 um councils but
interested but we not progress until the
detail has been
confirmed um is another
four so um the team has done I think an
excellent job of explaining why um
Parish Council who H who haven't
embarked on a neighborhood plan um might
want to take this um initiative forward
um and um yeah there's about 12 actively
working on one or or
creating but we would like a little more
clarity on on how it's going to be used
um by how it can be used by councils and
how it how it's going to be regarded by
national
government certainly Council Parker the
the clarity issue is is quite key here
but until we know a lot more then it's
it's very difficult to to make any
comment further on that and also the
other thing we need Clarity on is um the
funding for neighborhood plans generally
going forward because at the moment uh
it's only a one-year funding program up
until the end of March um the and that
was only uh made available from from
July it took three months from the end
of the last Financial year for the this
current Year's funding program to be um
to be allocated so um there there's a
lot of uncertainty over no plans at the
moment we'll have to wait and
see okay so um I
think if there are no more questions
then uh Council M did you want to
summarize at all before we move on there
is a final Slide the last uh page of
this report which just describes the
performance report Journey what we've
been trying to present collecting
information from the different
directorates and portfolios to present
uh this report in this format so in the
first quarter we developed the three
sections achievements direction of
travel future plans we've added in uh a
series of
kpis second report we're including some
kpis for statutory targets hoping to
reduce the number of slides I should say
but uh that's a difficult matter I'd
like by the way at this point to pay
tribute to Joe Hobs who's been
responsible for driving this work
forward and uh yeah we have spent a lot
of time discussing the presentation of
it um the next quarter we'll see
additional kpis um with Associated
targets and statuses the point about
kpis is you have to have a build up a
database to be able to present something
something you can measure against and
you can't do that from scratch you have
to be measuring consistently to actually
produce the figures in the first place
um and finally in section uh in quarter
four uh the end of the year and the full
cycle uh we'll be presenting an
additional selection of those and the
same statuses there's also a system
called pentana which is a configuration
that allows the directorate to produce
these reports um and that this going
forward is the
format of presentation that I'd like to
bring to council and cabinet rather
particularly to cabinet because I'm
hoping it'll make it uh understandable
why and how we measure performance and
the fact is that key behind all of this
is section one those 21 outcomes
actually I think there's 22 I found I
counted an extra one the other day but
those outcomes that's what we're based
upon we're looking for these specific
results outcomes thanks very much for
listening thank you Council MC so that
uh report is for noting
only and moving on then item 11 is
exclusion of the public and that uh it
does include the Press so to consider
whether pursuant part one of schedule
12a of the Local Government Act
1972 the public should be excluded from
the meeting for the business specified
Below on the grounds that if the public
were present during this item it is
likely that there would be the
disclosure to them of exempt information
as indicated against the item the author
of the report proposed to be considered
in part two of the agenda is satisfied
that the public interest in maintaining
the exemption outweighs the public
interest in disclosing the information
may I have a
proposal councilor saw may I have a
second councelor Helen
Davis and now we'll have
vote Sor oh show of hand we'll do vote
by show of hand
thank
you so that's unanimous and we'll
now close we'll now uh we'll now clo are
we in close session yet no not yet not
yet we will uh now be going into Clos
session having conducted that vote and
uh conduct the rest of the business
after we're in closed
session